foreign
42-year-old Cold Case has been solved
64-year-old Paul Nuttall faces murder
and sexual assault charges connected to
a young mother's murder back in 1980.
police say he raped and killed her in
her home near downtown Las Vegas our 8
news now investigators breaking the
story earlier today on 8newsnow.com and
David charns reports
according to police in December 1980
Sandra de Felice was discovered deceased
inside her bedroom at her home near
Bonanza and Maryland Parkway documents
the 82 investigators obtained revealing
the mother of a three-year-old girl was
found beaten and left for dead
detectives say defelice's roommate had
let nettle into the home but it was
unclear Friday if nuddle actually had
known the women before evidence at the
home included a fingerprint left on a
drinking glass and a man's DNA profile
found under di Felice's fingernails
last year investigators obtained a DNA
sample from nuttle which they say
matched the DNA found under di Felice's
nails nuttle now officially facing
charges of murder sexual assault and
burglary nearly 42 years after police
believe he committed the crimes I'm
David charns 8 News Now
not all by the way being held without
bail we expect more information from
Metro next week